[Music]
a damn good news for y'all we joined
Stephen Crowder's Network on Rumble yeah
protect us from getting deep platforms
oh they didn't come through this
with a non-profit they're backing they
weren't even political they were just
massively popular YouTubers in the
bodybuilding Community when YouTube was
really just getting started
from semen alone is 300 minutes
if you're serious right now so this is
hard okay Sammy and as they began to
speak out more they were penalized more
videos were demonetized that's a heat
did you tell us the heat suddenly their
live shows were filled with people who
were there not just to laugh but who had
their back sign up
it's on our website
this is unprofessional white people
y'all can figure this out
show me the muscles show me the
microwave they're going to be
exclusively members of the mug Club Army
Hodge twins uncensored coming to Mud
Club October 12th hey come on man that's
it that's the promo
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
higher rate check today lives of tick
tock is going to be on the show so uh
she was on a flight she just landed and
so we were having to work this out
before we just uh started to broadcast
this live so that's exciting because she
has some new uh some new Intel over
there on Twitter oh I didn't do my sip
a little bit a little bit crazy here
today we have a lot to talk about let me
give you the rundown you guys can see
this uh here we bring this up for you so
that way you know where to skip ahead in
chapters
um the former LA Dodgers pitcher you
know Trevor Bauer has been completely
exonerated for the sexual assault
allegations well remember he lost his
job he lost his contracts he lost his
reputation millions and uh dollars and
we'll show his recent video as well as
you know statements from the attorneys
and uh the media and the smear campaign
that was going on for a long time it's
always interesting to look back and say
okay we know that that is completely
untrue
well now let's look at everything that
we were told through that lens kind of
like the Johnny Depp Trail remember that
and then people going oh wait a second
you broke his finger with a bottle
's bed
the theme today is crazy your name if
you talk about The Crucible leave me my
name it's they take your name from you
they're doing that with Donald Trump too
so we'll go a brief update there might
be some more updates today on the the
trial taking place with Donald Trump
um Justin Trudeau a professional
blackface in Chief uh his government is
now in Canada they are coming for
podcasts meaning they want a registry of
everyone who is managing a a paywall
service
um a multimedia service a social media
platform anyone with subscriberships in
their country they want to have all of
your information and they want to be
able to control what is spoken about now
I've talked about this many many years
ago so um seeing it come to fruition I
guess that it's it's been happening for
a long time but it's worst is uh very
disturbing and then we have a higher
from lives of tick tock who's going to
be discussing Twitter censorship X
censorship is current censorship but X
let's just say Twitter guys right is it
okay you understand what I'm saying if I
say Twitter somebody asks us do you
trust that Elon Musk cares about the
best interest of American and Free
Speech or do you think he's playing both
sides on this a little bit we'll show
you some things that are disconcerting
but they might be coming from yakarino
more than uh more than Elon I just feel
weird saying that
and then before I go to you in third
chair here today
you know them you love them and they
have a major announcement they are
coming to mug Club October 12th
is when their show launches their
following show Keith and Kevin Hodge
Hodge twins how are you guys sirs oh
we're doing great man why are you
laughing at I don't like that picture
so your show right it's October 12th
October 12th looking forward to it
um believe it or not we do sense
ourselves on YouTube but it'd be great
to be able to say what we want to say
yeah you guys can say it on Rumble and
then of course you still get uh extra
content on where do they sign up for the
hutch twins yeah we're we're going to
get their website form I thought it was
the the hodgetwins.com or sorry
conservative twins.com Mud Club I
believe that's not sure but yeah I'll
make sure you sign up so that goes
through your portal and then people can
uh people can stick with the twins yeah
we're gonna need that link yeah you are
going to need that link
I don't know and you guys have never
done
really a full-length podcast
yeah we plan on doing an hour yeah
um and you know it's just be so great
that you can say what we want to say and
you got like an amazing platform I don't
think nobody
like take that into consideration what
you've been able to build on your own
it's like really amazing you you don't
have a network like NBC or Fox News you
did all this stuff on your own it's like
and to be a part of that it's going to
be well and you know what having the the
partnership with Rumble you know Mud
Club is Rumble Rumble is mug Club where
they have our backs and uh that's a
broader Network and mug Club is
underneath it where you get now
Hodgetwins Alex Jones on Friday soon to
be daily with Alex Jones Mr guns are
gonna get Brian Collins weekly show you
get Nick depalo every day at 5 PM so I
get it out there you guys hey you have
tip fatigue right there's a patreon here
and there's a network there we're
looking to grow something that uh
provides you with enough people that you
actually want to watch that is the idea
of that is the model is hey who do
people care and already support let's
make sure you get them all with one
membership so uh you can sign up I know
at lotto.com but then also they'll have
their own page all right Gerald a number
two CEO how are you you should have the
landing pages
yeah I'll take that one I'm doing well
I'm fighting a little sickness but yeah
I'm doing well just making me a little
tired yeah is that why you were a cold
fish yesterday I wasn't a cold fish you
were a dead fish yesterday
I came out of the gate a little slow
I'll admit that yeah you did well you're
right I finished strong
he finishes in five minutes remember
that yeah he was like yeah you know it's
just five minutes of gratification you
have to think about the rest of your
life and we're like Gerald that's not
going to be received the way you think
it's
five minutes not bad yeah that's what
she said
it's certainly not impressive all right
if we're if we're having some honest
real talk here
let's do it five minutes is it bad yeah
right yeah yeah yeah yeah that's yeah
don't worry it happens to lots of guys
and before we go on to our first story
here
anyway before we go on to our first
story because of what the first story
[Music]
thank you
because you know I just I'm not going to
lose that word yeah they can just hit it
really quickly sure it doesn't sounds
like Morse code sometimes
so I think we're fine with this next
story but you never know
um just watch it on Rumble anyway that's
the best place to watch it you don't
even need to put your money where your
mouth is put your free click where your
mouth is and take money away from people
who hate everything about you so this
trans person
claims that if you were to put them up
next to a woman uh now let me preface
this first that you wouldn't be able to
tell the difference now I guess it
depends on the woman
but and you'll see in the with the clip
in question you wouldn't be able to tell
the difference if you put them next to
uh an antique can opener so it's a very
wide spectrum of one of these things is
just like the other but they are
claiming no difference between
themselves and a biological woman
let's let you be the judge my vagina
looks as functions as stretches like any
other vagina in the world
I have the ability to get the same types
of infections that everybody else I can
get a yeast infection I can get no
dental care good for you get UTIs I
don't have an open wound I don't need
wound care I need vaginal health because
mentally all those infections I have the
potential for cancer in the lining of my
vagina like everybody else
so you may not like the fact that
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
to hear that they have cervical cancer
thanks Dr
no no I said prostate cancer we'll say
cervical I'll find I'll write down
whatever you want you're gonna die the
way yeah okay
us
it's cancer either way it's bad right
yeah yeah by the way the BMI well which
chart are we using I go we're using a I
was going to say your BMI for a a man is
not great oh a woman yeah this is
morbidly obese you're you are also going
to die so hey you know what the good
news is if the cancer doesn't get you
first your heart will probably give out
anyway
um quick yeah yeah by the way notice all
the things that this transgender
individual brags about uh it stretches
like and by the way I'm skeptical Color
Me skeptical if you guys can comment
below I don't necessarily know that by
all of it but they don't mention
climaxing eighty percent of male to
female transgenders can never achieve
orgasm again oh oh that's a
hot no wonder the suicide rate is so
high what kind of life is that not
having an orgasm yeah think about that
that's five minutes you'll never get
back you wake up you're like wow
you want people got all the good jokes
it's five minutes
[Laughter]
oh my God another we need to talk about
it did she uh well I called her she is
she talking about her anus or she get
one of those no it's like it's like what
they do is they fillet your wings and by
the way like we've always said kids
should not be watching the show we are
informing you that you can protect your
children from the evil of the world it's
a PG-13 plus this is a drag kid
shouldn't but what they actually do is
they they fillet your wiener like you
ever go to Five Guys and you get the hot
dog yeah they cut it down the middle
yeah yeah so it's that and they stuff it
up in yeah so horrible John looks like a
belly butt yeah a deep belly button yeah
that's probably what it looks like well
that guy's belly button you may not like
that I go to a gynecologist it's like we
don't think about it we don't care but
that's life you have to deal with it no
no you have to deal with no orgasms and
apparently you yeast infections it is
man and by the way the yeast infection
doesn't require a vagina it's probably
in your fat folds it also happens there
that's true it's my second vagina Gohan
it is true and you know it's disturbing
everything yeah everything but she won't
get fat checked at all no no no no no no
no no no no no not at all no Brave and
beautiful
yes does need to lay off the meth but
Brave and beautiful well you know what
it comes with its perks she can open
your cans
you may not like it but I don't care
just can you open this this is baked
beans and thank you I'll put it over a
fireplace
and we're the extremists think about
this according to Big Tech we are the
extremists you may not like that I have
inverted my penis you may not like that
I am proud of my yeast infection
humanism I just don't want you telling
kids that it's a good idea because it's
bad for them it's unhealthy not to
mention look you guys are in the
bodybuilding World obviously steroids
are rampant yeah we know what happens if
you have excess testosterone in the body
what do you do you guys have any idea
what happens to the male physiology with
obscenely high estrogen levels excess
estrogen cancer cancer of course it
happens in women let alone men yeah
cancer yeah that's why women get cancer
more often than men in like in Nebraska
and one of the first things that they do
if a woman gets breast cancer is they
use what a lot of bodybuilders in
aromatase inhibitor yeah they use that
to reduce their estrogen because it
decreases allegedly the proliferation of
cancerous cells so even with women
excess estrogen can be a problem now you
need estrogen right the key is in the
dose and men have less by Design just
like they have far more testosterone
than women and I think of all of these
transgender experiments that we're going
through women with testosterone I don't
think it's going to be good for them
obviously but I think estrogen in men
particularly young men developing young
men yeah puberty it's dangerous that is
that is you are putting them in a
shallow cancerous grave 42 attempted
suicide rate pre and post-op and cancer
rates Skyrocket with every single
percentage point of estrogen in the
bloodstream that goes up
that due to so mentally ill you know
when he's uh having sex he's like check
out my vagina
there's a bigger it stretches it's
getting wet
I'm aroused
ah you got like Reebok Pump Action only
it's an inverted Five Guys split hot dog
wow you're the woman of my dreams yeah
imagine Lake no okay let's not imagine
oh man it feels great
oh God we have their landing page now
save it for yourself I've asked for it
so all right mug club and whoever signs
up today will make sure it's just
considered there you go uh and then you
guys will get that out there I think
yeah we've had some issues with the URLs
hey I blame Canada now let's go on to uh
this really quickly Trevor Bauer um well
I guess a former Dodgers uh pitcher now
the best he was he was one of the best
he signed a giant free agent deal he'd
won the Cy Young Award okay and was a
phenomenal best pitcher out there on the
market I didn't know anything about him
other than the sexual assault
allegations right now let me clarify
this before we go to the clip and it's a
little bit longer because I want to
provide some context here because this
is one of
this is one of the worst problems that
we're facing right now in society
because this kind of smear campaign
character assassination is the reason
that young men are not seeking out young
women will not talk to young women and
it's the reason that young women say
there are no men
worth talking to or marrying out there
there is a breakdown not just of
marriage but of relationships in younger
generations and it's based on fear and
that stems from a lot of the false me
too it does it didn't get worse because
rape went up rape has gone down just to
be clear sexual assault has gone down
false accusations have gone up and so
men are saying it's not worth the risk
and then women are saying well well but
but where am I going to find a man with
you know a seven-figure income who's six
foot two uh and is willing to you know
give me everything that I want well you
know he doesn't want to be falsely
accused of rape so uh this man Aaron
Rodgers sorry not Aaron Rodgers Scott
Trevor Bauer I was
might know Aaron Rodgers
also old Sanders Berry yeah well
yeah all right Church chili Trevor Bauer
has finally been exonerated now to be
clear the accusations
um they came from a woman named Lindsay
Hill yeah she accused Bauer of choking
and punching her now the consequences
were Major League Baseball is suspended
bar for 194 games they docked his pay
for the first 50 games of 2023 then he
was cut by the Dodgers and now he plays
in the Japanese league so there's a
silver lining because he's probably much
larger than them
I think she's making more money too I I
you know what I don't know but I'm sure
that this guy obviously if he's one of
the best in other words this was not
based on um performative aspects of his
job being a good pitcher not at all it
was based on a smear campaign and guilty
until proven innocent well he's proven
innocent now
but does he get that back and here's the
thing that's really important too I want
to run this clip you need to understand
the difference between what takes place
in court
versus uh what takes place in the court
of public opinion and the difference
between rape and sexual assault and um
defamation so he didn't quite get
financial damages for defamation but it
was ruled that no sexual assault took
place that's important to note right so
that I want to add one quick thing here
too with the MLB they the D.A I believe
declined to bring any charges saying
that there was no real case to be able
to bring I don't know if they had all
this evidence and this was a civil suit
that we were talking about here
but he was reinstated by the Major
League Baseball by Major League Baseball
and no one would sign him because of
this last year this guy has been playing
in Japan because reinstated fully
cleared nobody in baseball would touch
him because of the allegation right and
how they were made and how this metoo
Mania got away from everybody oh by the
way remind me after this we won I wanted
to hit the the Trump update on the over
evaluation I guess that's what we'll do
it after
um okay so Lindsey Bauer accused him of
choking and punching her what she would
think you know you'd be able to prove
yeah yeah you know he's a big guy
professional athlete she had pictures
she doctored all this stuff yeah yeah
you'll see she had doctor's pictures so
last night
um Bauer released this video of him
detailing the case because now and this
is something else what often happens is
in order to protect the victim you're
often Bound by like a gag order while
the case is ongoing and you're in court
so you cannot speak out and defend
yourself and you were attacked instead
in the court of public opinion
regardless of what's going on in court
so what you for example what you heard
about Johnny Depp and Amber Heard wasn't
true
until finally they had a trial that was
broadcast
we all thought we knew right we were all
wrong this happened this happened many
times so let's go through this video
here that Bauer released um I believe it
was last night detailing specifically
how the case has gone down now next
victim star pitcher for the Dodge these
are texts from the ones Lindsay Hill
sent to a friend before she ever even
met me what should I steal she asked
another in reference to visiting my
house for the first time the answer take
his money
so how might that work I'm going to his
house Wednesday she said I already have
my hooks in you know how I roll
then after the first time we met net
worth is 51 mil she said you
better secure the bag was the response
but but how is she going to do that need
daddy to choke me out she said being an
absolute to try to get in on his
51 million read another text geez then
after the second time people say you
know with guys like hey don't hate the
player uh hate the game no in this case
you hate the player yeah this case you
hate the player how do I steal his money
I will fake abuse and plan it no one
will fact check me on that and by the
way even if I lose in court the damage
will already be done and I have a book
deal yep the man doesn't get his name
back all right let's continue
Padres pitcher Jacob Nix told her you
got to get this bag I'll give you fifty
thousand Lindsay replied her AAA sponsor
asked her at one point do you feel a
tiny bit guilty not really she replied
since then her legal team has approached
me multiple times about coming to a
financial settlement but as I have done
since day one I refuse to pay her even a
single Cent
in August of 2021 Lindsay Hill's claims
were heard in court and during those
legal proceedings critical information
was deliberately and unlawfully
concealed for me and my legal team uh
information like this video which was
taken by Lindsey Hill herself the
morning after she claimed she was
brutally attacked emotionally
traumatized and desperate to get away
from me it's a face of it now we have
the metadata so there can be no dispute
it was taken mere minutes before she
left my house on the morning of May 16
2021 without my knowledge or consent of
course now pause that really quickly
because I want to go to by the way her
lawyer um here's the thing you need to
know this is a Shakedown obviously right
yeah this came out publicly and before
anything transpired in court her legal
team said hey you could offer some money
because this might be uncomfortable and
her lawyer uh Brian Freeman categorized
this a very different way than it
actually went down but her lawyer in
August of 2021 Brian Friedman released
photos of Hill's black eye let's bring
that up that's overlay C1 so that was
released right from my understanding the
day that you just saw that video or it
was alleged that it was from the day
that you just saw that video her lawyer
Brian Friedman
was involved with releasing those that
went to Daily Mail wow and then they
went to this man and said if you give us
some money
if you give us some money this can all
go away according to Friedman her lawyer
it said look at this picture no one
absolutely no one can consent to this
logically or legally on April 2022
Friedman asked TMZ to publish photos
showing Hills injuries bring up bring up
that previous overlay really quickly
of Friedman here Trevor Bauer's team
continues to try to abuse an assault
victim they need to stop now so so
you're not just going after Trevor Bauer
you were going after the Dodgers as well
the organization yeah maybe trying to
shake them down for some money maybe a
payout there right
hey no one can absolutely consent to
this logically or legally first off um
no
mostly because that didn't happen
according to the eviction yeah and by
the way I've met some people who are
into some weird stuff where you're like
I don't even know if you can consent to
that legally it's like look they grew up
in that area of Germany where that's
their thing yeah it's always Germany so
here's the question does the lawyer know
that it's true or not right right the
legal team approaching Trevor uh Bauer
right Trevor Bauer Bauer Chevrolet I
know you're not a baseball I want to say
Jack Bauer I'm thinking of 24. look at
this picture said the lawyer Daily Mail
no one absolutely no one can consent to
this legally or logically oh but now we
just saw that video from the day in
question and that'll that that's
important because you'll see the
changing of tact you'll see that
changing of tag afterwards uh once what
was declared in court uh came to be
final let's continue playing this video
my heart breaks for the guy you can see
her lying in bed next to me while I'm
sleeping smirking at the camera without
a care in the world or any marks on her
face
I think it paints a pretty clear picture
of what actually happened the evening of
May 15th and why the video was
originally concealed from us boring sex
regular yeah after hearing the evidence
available to her judge Diana gold
saltman found that Lindsey Hill had
misled the court she found her claims to
be materially misleading she denied her
request for a domestic violence
restraining order and she found that no
sexual assault or non-consensual conduct
took place now some of you might not
know about restraining order hearings I
know I didn't but I've since learned
that it's extremely rare for a request
for a restraining order to be denied
because the standard of proof that you
need
to obtain one is extremely low
can confirm
so you can make of that what you will
the fact is I was never arrested I was
never charged with a crime and I won the
only legal proceeding that took place
without my side of the story even being
heard
and most importantly as I've said from
day one I never sexually assaulted
Lindsey Hill or anyone else for that
matter
so I sued her which prompted her to
countersue me quite frankly regardless
of the outcome in court I've paid
significantly more in legal fees than
Lindsey Hill could ever pay me in her
entire life and I knew that would be the
case going in but and by the way pause
was never about them I'm sure I don't
know how much they brought it back that
was of course framed as bullying right
that was when he sued her yeah for
defamation and to be clear he was found
completely innocent of any type of
sexual assault and the restraining order
shot down which like he said the burden
of the burden of proof the threshold to
just enforced restraining order because
it's not that much of a hassle right to
a judge is really really low that means
there was absolutely nothing there but
if you go back and you read the articles
for example at TMZ probably page six
maybe Perez Hilton maybe Daily Mail
whoever this person the attorneys
reached out to and issued their
statements they framed it as though
Bauer was a bully it was abusive it was
coercive control bullying and suing her
for defamation to intimidate the victim
when in reality this was a man who was
having his life ruined it's important
when you look back and go okay what were
we told yeah it is the exact opposite of
the truth because they know how you're
going to react and this man had to live
through hell think about that he sued
her for defamation which is very very
difficult to do by the way it's a public
figure that's a totally separate issue
and I don't believe that he got any
significant finances from it but he was
exonerated from any type of sexual
assault how many people know that all
right let's continue for me
the only way for me to obtain critical
information to clear my name
the discovery process in that lawsuit
recently concluded at which point
Lindsay Hill's legal team again came to
us with another proposal to resolve the
case
this time however they weren't seeking
any money from me
having received much of the information
that had been hidden from us a small
portion of which I've referenced here I
was willing to agree to the terms
proposed both parties would drop their
respective lawsuits and neither of us
would pay either side any money
I also retained my right to speak
publicly about the case something I have
not been at Liberty to do since June of
2021. ah pause that now imagine that
right this is what happens with a lot of
these people especially if you're
talking about a criminal accusation
um like sexual assault and abuse gag
order can't talk about it now
obviously this attorney had no problem
discussing it and posting pictures
publicly so what was going on in court
by the way that I'm willing to bet that
those pictures were never admissible in
court at all to any degree well those
are doctored it's very clear once they
saw the video but you only saw the
pictures the people in court people
involved in the case who knew that it
was false were under a gag order where
they could not discuss it this guy went
from 2021 until last night where he had
to let his name be run through the mud
this is how the system works they're
Shakedown artists in Hollywood
they will sit down and go we can shake
this person down for money this was
plotted from the beginning with a
selfish woman who was trying to take
advantage of this man you saw it in
those texts then she went and said who
can I find who's going to help me do
this and leak this out to the Press
because I know I won't win this in court
boom there you go how you hurt you rang
said I guess her attorney Brian Friedman
let's keep watching
lawsuits have
been I've been forced to defend my
integrity and my reputation in a very
public setting but hopefully this is the
last time I have to do so as I'd prefer
to just remain focused on doing my job
winning baseball games and entertaining
fans around the world so today I'm happy
to be moving on with my life all right
I'm glad he's got a good attitude about
it I would Lindsey Hill needs to go to
jail yes she targeted somebody she lied
about something that happened she
obviously faked injuries either by
doctoring photos or by having somebody
beat the crap out of her or by makeup or
something like that right having a liar
liar in the bathroom exactly somebody
beat the crap out of her so that she
could get money
and then sold it to these attorneys who
did no due diligence at all who then
leaked this information to put public
pressure to seek a settlement that was
it right that's that's the game plan and
he wins and still lost yeah you don't
get to be the best at anything and
that's spending your life doing it you
took that away from him he was at the
top of his game just on a three-year
deal I think it was 105 million dollars
120 million dollars I can't remember
lots and lots and lots of money that all
vanishes all of the sponsors vanished
all of the extra money all of his
friends and family vanished potentially
because now he's a sexual abuser he has
to go to Japan a year after already
being cleared because the D.A said
there's nothing here for me to do I
can't bring charges on this case because
the major league baseball guys are too
chicken to hire him yeah because the
metoo movement will be picketing right
outside because this story never gets
told and that's why he's an abuser and
they give you option number one or
number two they go hey this can all go
public we have pictures of black guys
and this may get to uh you know Daily
Mail I don't know I might get the page
six might get to it'll get out there as
a point or here's a bunch of money which
we now know is her goal in the first
place and you can say well awesome but
none of that's true yeah but you know by
the time you go through Court in the
trial I'm willing to bet that maybe some
calls are made to the Major League
Baseball yeah uh folks and uh you
probably lose your job and you'll be on
some Japanese game show with a hose in
your face
and then they show up and you're like oh
no how can this be they have no idea
he's a giant but here's how her attorney
right the liar Lindsey Hill her attorney
um Brian Friedman characterized the
trial he said listen to this Trevor
Bauer sued Lindsey Hill for defamation
in what turned out to be an outstanding
resolution for Lindsay neither Lindsay
nor anyone on her behalf paid anything
to Bauer not a single dollar even better
Lindsay received 300 000 from her
insurance company based on that payment
what Lindsay agreed to settle the
lawsuit now that the lawsuit is over
Lindsay looks forward to helping others
oh she looks forward to helping others
helping others ruin men's lives based on
lies yes oh man that attorney has got to
be complicit in all this what do you
think yeah um isn't that insurance fraud
seems like it does it seems like there's
a lot of fraud going on here it seems
like again Lindsey Hill is a criminal
yeah if somebody doesn't prosecute her
there is no justice yes there is no
justice in this case if somebody does
not prosecute Lindsey Hill right now you
have every bit of the evidence that you
need go make it happen and the promise
defamation is so hard defamation is so
hard these are actual crimes of course
but this is the issue right and look
there are people out there who talk
about this there is no accountability
for certain Bad actors out there in the
press and largely yeah that does take
place on the feminist side with women
right me too was a Haven for women to
lie and shake down people for money this
is a guy let me ask you this what do you
think happens after this
hey Bauer you think that for most women
probably a catch right let's say he's
not even necessarily your type but you
add a few inches of height
and a couple hundred million dollars
he's kind of cute
he's no longer available
men like that check out and say I'm not
going through that again and then women
say there aren't any high value men out
there for me well why do you think so
and now you have an entire generation of
young men coming up right who have seen
these stories take place so even if it
hasn't happened to them there ironically
like a battered housewife they are
saying there's no way I'm waiting into
that Quagmire absolutely not I'll just
play video games and watch pornography
and we see sexual dysfunction going up
this is a serious problem when there is
no accountability for one of the two
sexes
and men can have their lives destroyed
through the court of public opinion with
people who decide to act outside of the
boundaries of the law guess what before
we even get to marriages
the the Romancing the courting of men
and women
ceases to be
and what do you think should happen to
people who make these false sexual
assault allegations or false abuse
allegations or coercion right the
defamation I remember I always thought
that was so funny like he's trying to
he's trying to intimidate her this is
more of his bullying more of his
bullying suing her to try this is victim
shaming hold on a second that's what
they always do right this is that that's
the projection oh I was raped no no no
hold on a second no she wasn't she
absolutely wasn't I have video proof
that that never happened I never choked
her and I never punched her see this is
victim blaming again what a wonderful
way to remove any and all accountability
but hey the Press loves a good story
this guy doesn't get his name back
sad sad yeah
um that's all let's talk about toxic man
is these toxic women ruining people's
lives like I have something similar to
happen to me it was like a family member
yeah me too I was I was with you yeah
she called me up it was like um a second
couldn't punched a family member during
sex no no she
tried to extort me for money oh
um
[Music]
and she's claiming that you sexually
assaulted her yeah that's like that
never happened she said well tell you
what if you don't give me fifteen
thousand dollars chump change if
you don't give me fifteen thousand
dollars I'm going to ten
thank you
[Music]
foreign
leaving my name it's shaming it's
ruining someone's name reputation hit
the like button by the way if you want
to show Bauer some support maybe we can
yeah if we don't have them on the show
because I don't think he wants to
discuss this anymore he might not he
might be one we can reach out behind the
scenes because like a lot of people here
we know a lot of folks have been through
very similar situations
um the Trump Civil Trial very similar
right so the first day wrapped up we
don't have all the information now we
will as the show goes on but uh you know
this trial is largely about Donald Trump
inflating property values to secure
these loans right they're trying to say
that he lied about the value of his
assets right okay so first off let me
just show you something the proof again
in the media so what you hear is yeah he
inflated the value of his assets he lied
so that he could get uh loans he
defrauded banks right he defrauded
lenders okay so this is from Sun
Sentinel where actually the judge ruled
that the Mar-A-Lago estate is worth 18
million dollars
18 million dollars I think we have a
picture by the way let's have it bring
up a picture of Mar-A-Lago I think
that's it it's the win the independence
the uh is that do we have that
let's get an aerial shot where people
can see let's compare Mar-A-Lago so 18
million dollars it is 17 Acres with 90
rooms
square feet yeah directly the house is
62 000 square feet okay there's a house
either down I think it's just down the
street yeah 7 200 square feet on a much
much much smaller lot sold for 53
million dollars how many how many
bedrooms does that one have Stephen that
one has still more than I even know
about five I believe something like that
um oh so five bedrooms 53 million
dollars 90 plus rooms eighteen we did
have eight and a half baths oh that
might have been Ben Carson he loves the
best y'all don't know it's uh palm trees
around that whole property right yeah
like probably a couple hundred yeah each
one of those palm trees is like around
forty thousand dollars yeah here's
another here's another one a much
smaller lot look at that far from 7 18
million I'll put in an offer right now
Stephen can you finance me yeah yeah
nope here's somebody here's one uh not
too far on a 1.5 acre lot Far Cry from
almost 20. so it's a 24 000 square foot
house okay bigger bigger not still less
it's still about a third okay 1.5 Acres
okay it's 4.5 miles from Mar-A-Lago yeah
it was estimated to be worth 116 million
dollars how many bedrooms
not 90 plus rooms but eight bedrooms
those must be really big bedrooms as a
matter of fact I challenge you to find
me any property with it with a house on
there that is let's say let's say the
threshold needs to be um
7 000 square feet or larger okay seven
thousand square feet and more than one
and a half acres that is waterfront
property near Mar-A-Lago find me
anything that is below 18 million
dollars and you guys can send it to me
find me a single one that is sold in the
last two years or is valued at 18
million dollars the actual value of
Marlo just the property would be well
into the hundreds of millions of dollars
this is how you know the system is
rigged the judge said probably doesn't
know anything about real estate
investment uh I don't know I asked G you
said 18 million seemed about right
and here's the crazy thing too just so
you guys know
the loans were paid back with interest
the people who loaned the money so if
Donald Trump artificially inflated the
value let's say of like Mar-A-Lago right
I'm using that because that's an example
that we have let's say he artificially
said no it's worth I want 3 billion but
he's only worth two and he gets a loan
the banks weren't complaining the
lenders weren't complaining they were
paid back with interest there are no
victims of these so-called crimes that
is what we do know it's no fraud yeah
don't the banks determine what the homes
value back from well the banks are the
ones that go yeah sure I'll lend to you
yeah and if they don't care yeah they
don't care the banks don't care this is
about this is this is a witch targeting
yeah this is targeting by the way this
is the 22nd largest home in the United
States yeah what they're saying is worth
18 million yeah we drove down that just
to view alone just stay in the Atlantic
Ocean it's like a nuts to go from Mexico
whatever it's beautiful it's like the
waters blue it's like it's amazing right
there that's like one of the richest
areas in the world yeah by the way I
think I think we have a you have houses
no no go back to that you have houses in
that picture and I know it's hard to see
those houses but there are other houses
that are not Mar-A-Lago but that are
worth more than 18 million look at the
giant house now look at the other
property yeah the holes
judge look at all the palm trees those
things are 40 000
is over 18 million now by the way of
course to me it's largely ridiculous
when people have these remember like
Mike Tyson had what was weird to me is
he had a house that had like 12 bedrooms
but it had like 24 bathrooms yeah yeah
yeah why do you need more bathrooms than
Rome well this house drugs some of these
houses had the same thing where they had
like yeah trucks you never know when
you're gonna need a toilet to flush them
down right you never know
yeah
there's a house so anyways that's the
that's what we have right now so this is
going to be prosecuted James is trying
to argue about the statue of limitations
yes is not up when in fact the statute
of limitations is up and you had a judge
who said yeah it's worth 18 million
dollars this is a rigged system and by
the way just like it's rigged you just
saw with with uh with uh Mr Bauer right
the pitcher you see it with Donald Trump
if people want to Target you they're
going to Target you and you have dumb
asses out there who actually believe
that Donald Trump artificially inflated
the value of Mar-A-Lago you right now
probably have people on the street I bet
you 30 of Americans maybe 25 who believe
that Donald Trump lost to Stormy Daniels
in court and that his house is worth 18
million dollars there are those people
walking the Earth today yes by the way
this is the second time the statute of
limitations is basically they're trying
to move it the first time was with the
defamation lawsuits that he lost for
five million dollars what they did I
can't remember the lady's name that it
was uh against but whatever she she was
not his type apparently and then he
reiterated and got sued Again by her for
another five million dollars which I
think he's gonna lose but this time the
statute of limitations ran out in 2014
yeah nine years ago and they're like no
no it shouldn't matter your honor what
your honor it shouldn't matter
considering the severity of this case
where he overvalued his assets to
receive loans that he paid back with
interest what kind of a precedent do we
want to sit here
I mean the banks are happy now we can't
have that I wish it was just like judge
general just shut the get the
out of my courtroom
hey these cases they're civil cases
right yeah in these cases but they
always try and they you know they try
and turn into something uh criminal as
well criminal right Woody you think I'm
for raping a you know um wait what
um
yes like because the burden of proof in
the Civil Trial which you need
two-thirds of the vote to go think he's
guilty you don't need a full you well
yeah you need a reasonable uh you know
reason no yeah I don't think you need
two Sizzle but yeah for civil you need
Reasonable Doubt in other words it's not
Beyond uh all doubt like that's how OJ
got found guilty in the Civil Trial
right and the murder trial because there
was a cop who said the n-word I don't
know what it is
guilty in both trucks well once he wrote
the book If I Did It Forward written
forward written by I did I think you did
it all right so uh let's move on here
too do we have time to talk about the
Canada podcast before uh got about I got
about eight minutes all right so let's
rattle this one this one matters because
look I always say to you what what would
liberals do what would the Democrats do
if left completely consider not with the
checks and balances that we have you
have a pretty good idea as to what they
would do you saw it with covid but
Canada is a great experiment to to look
to and hopefully eventually take over
I'd love to see us take over Canada make
it the 51st state game for them you know
people are going to accuse us of being
an advice
um take the oil you've heard me talk
about this many times Free Speech
doesn't exist outside the United States
okay it does not exist so earlier this
year the Canadian government passed this
uh Bill a uh bill c-11
which regulated the way services like
Netflix and YouTube operated in the
country
okay
now let me just set that up now they're
going to extend this to podcasts they're
going to extend this to people who have
online uh digital platforms Like Yours
Truly and places like Rumble the
Canadian government is going to demand
all of that information be handed over
just like you know just like their gun
registry so at the time of the original
Bill conservative opposition leader uh
Pierre perlier
however you guys say it in a minute I'm
not trying to be affected it's like I
have 15 friends who have that last name
it's like Smith in French Canada
he warned back then
regarding the implications of the bill
[Applause]
day
sorry wrong clip here's the one question
Justin Trudeau has tried to shut down
competition by passing censorship laws
that give a powerful Central bureaucracy
the the to the control over what
Canadians see and say what that bill
will do is reinforce oligopolies it will
limit the number of voices that can
compete for Canadians interest
I don't think that Canadians should be
forced just to listen to the powerful
corporate or state-funded media I think
that it should be free speech freedom of
the press and then let Canadians decide
what they read what they see and what
they believe online
fast forward
and services with Revenue over 10
million dollars will have to register
with the crtc that's like their
equivalent of uh kind of like the FTC or
like the FTC kind of but it's a silly
place so here's a quote from the
National Post such Services include
streaming services social media Services
subscription Television services that
are available online this includes
podcasts so this will include Yours
Truly this will include Rumble and we'll
get to their responses here uh this is
very scary when you consider the kind of
information that they want and the kind
of control that they have exerted in
Canada keep in mind this is the country
that froze the bank accounts of truckers
protesting lockdowns this guy this guy
gets a thrill Trudeau at removing your
civil rights the only two people who I
think actually it's it's almost they get
that god-like thrill that a serial
killer gets you know when they take
another life that's what I've heard is
they get they get this you can't say
that with that must uh
you look suspect a little bit yeah
no oh boy
these guys get a thrill I've said this
two times
Trudeau Whitmer they get a thrill off
out of removing your civil rights um and
we actually do I guess we have staff's
reaction um right now as the news is
breaking yeah
[Music]
guys you see this Netflix and Canada
they're starting to regulate all this
podcasts everything
who gives a yeah tell me when
they've been overrun by Venezuelan so I
could also not care I don't know not
pierre-polivia guys it's pretty dashing
what the hell Gary
[Music]
you know Gary he's he's pure of heart so
yeah
this bill this means that uh that all of
these services and this information will
have to be provided to the government
the crtc addresses
numbers and emails the types of services
offers offered and who is actually
subscribing look there is no reason to
live in Canada anymore unless you you
personally have a fetish for living
under a gay dictator Putin that's one
other thing that's those are the only
two things leave the country Hey Stephen
don't you think it's a
I don't know you think it's a
coincidence you just moved Mud Club over
to rumble and all of a sudden this
breaks
no no I don't I think they've been
targeting all of the top creators on
Rumble well yes they will Target handle
itself yes they've been targeting all
the top Traders on Rumble and this is
also the problem with look conservatives
playing ball with big tech companies
because guess what YouTube is probably
thrilled about this oh yeah they're
probably behind you
they want to work yeah hey we'll turn
over the information gladly these other
guys they won't so we can deal with it
bring the regulation so Jordan Peterson
actually um uh he posted this on X I was
gonna say tweet it out he x'd out at um
uh that doesn't sound right new speech
in Canada if it ever existed does not
exist now now
we love Jordan Peterson I love Jordan we
were the one back with Bill c-16 had him
on before he was really out here in the
states and and I've been saying for a
long time it doesn't exist in Canada
Free Speech only exists in the United
States period people will tell you no no
remember that Newsroom clip with uh Jeff
uh Daniel he's like what Freedom Belgium
has Freedom no they don't no they don't
they do not have freedom in Canada it is
a lie it is a facade just like you
thought you had freedom in Australia
until you were put in quarantine camps
Chris pavlovsky the CEO of Rumble and
brass pendulous balls I couldn't be
happier just to be clear to be in
business with these people these are the
only people and by that I mean the only
people pushing back and this guy was
raised in the
the that is Canada what he said
was Canada is no longer part of the Free
World as a Canadian I've never been more
embarrassed than I have these past few
weeks so let me ask you this if we see
what they do in places like uh the UK
places all across Europe where Free
Speech does not exist you now see what
is taking place in Canada
do you think that free speech is going
to continue to exist in the United
States of America comment below do you
think it's something that connect do you
think you can keep it do you think you
can protect it
because people will often say big tech
oh well on a second that does it's not
government go create your own second now
we've added another rate limiting factor
not just protection for these big tech
companies but you have to register all
of your information with the government
a government who by the way have already
said that they will make certain
information impermissible to post yeah
there's a there's a Ministry of Truth
I don't know I'm using that term it's a
Monty Python thing but they actually had
a panel conclusively and and this is
something look guys
you can go back go back to the blue bed
sheet days if you if you need to I have
been talking about this for many many
years on this channel I I didn't know
that it would get as Extreme as it has
been uh in the United States this
quickly
um or certainly the government using a
registry to get all of your I thought
they would just censor what you said on
big Tech platforms I didn't think they
would get your mailing address
I've been telling you about this warning
about it for years here's an old clip so
you would be okay with like Canadian law
where you can be jailed for quote
unquote hate speech or find yeah
I've just passed a bill where uh you can
actually depending on how you read it
legally you can be fined or you can be
jailed for misusing uh gender pronouns
for someone who's transgender really
you can be punished for that legally
what if you I mean at that point right
legally it's either it's illegal or it's
not so then it becomes is it by accident
or is it on purpose either way is it
something that should be a punishable
offense
okay so we said that we've said that's
not hate speech so in other words
they're trying to break down the First
Amendment rights in Canada well they
don't have a First Amendment
no other country has a First Amendment
outside the United States
yeah free speech doesn't exist outside
the United States a lot of people don't
know that hmm
they were shocked back then here laws
regarding pronouns
yeah what about now hey the same same
place that will jail you for using the
wrong pronouns now wants the address of
anyone who subscribes to a platform that
may not use their new made up pronouns
oh my wow or Orwell undershot it
they tend to pass the same legislation
in uh California Michigan right they're
trying to pass it all across the United
States if they had their if the left had
their way they would be able to remove
anything that they don't like right what
they instead they do is they ensure that
things get demonetized and throttled
classified as hate speech misinformation
which brings us to this next Story by
the way please hit the like button
whether you're on YouTube or on Rumble
[Music]
preferably on Rumble uh and and comment
below because it helps with the
algorithm because they do not want you
to see this next story
um lives of tick tock they've been very
effective right and uh I think I'm
pronounced I know it's higher I believe
it's higher rate chick as a person
behind lives of tick tock
Twitter X now is often seen as the Free
Speech sort of platform right
um especially as it relates to breaking
news and they've touted it as a go-to
medium or they want you to bring your
business there as independent
journalists but yeah they're been and we
we always said we're cautiously
optimistic
um recent findings by uh highlights of
tick tock have put into question just
how free the platform is so before we
get to the experiment that she's
actually run the evidence that she's
actually presenting and I highly
encourage you to go follow her and
support it let's go back to Friday uh
the new X CEO Twitter sorry I know it's
very convoluted Linda yakarino who
ironically never stops yakking announced
that the company was hey all this and
this is this is something that should
surprise you've been paying attention
the company is finally close to being
profitable we have a good set of eyes on
what is predictable and what's coming it
looks like in early 24 for we'll be
turning a profit so that's exciting is
something odd about someone saying a
good set of eyes wearing day Medina
glasses but
so we're close to making a profit in
July of 2023 Elon Musk he made the
statement that the company had lost 50
percent of its ad Revenue interesting
that's a very very fast turn around in
other words something changed yeah so
Elon Musk purchased Twitter right that
was a big deal I was really glad that he
did thought it would shake things up
then Twitter lost a bunch of Revenue
because I said hey this is this is a
hate speech as opposed to free speech we
don't want to invest in Twitter and
advertisers are pulling out and the
advertisers weren't pulling out because
the user base wasn't there the
advertisers were pulling out because of
the giant multi-international
conglomerates right these corporations
saying you better pull out otherwise
you're going to ensure that you can't
play at the table ESG scores all of that
we covered it okay okay so then it's
back up 50 percent
went down when Elon purchased it was
going to be free speech platform
something changed Revenue went down now
revenue is up
50 and they think they're going to be
profitable by next year that means
something again changed how did they
attract so many advertisers back that
had left yeah I think I think Elon might
be with the Linda yaccarino thing kind
of this is a theory kind of playing both
sides a little bit she came from NBC
Universal not exactly a champion of free
speech that's what got Elon in trouble
is he got all free speechy on Twitter
and that became a problem for all of
these people who like to silence things
like you know the hunter Biden laptop
which would have changed the outcome of
the 2020 election we've covered it a
million times right I think this gives
him the both sides angle Linda can go
out and talk to advertisers and be like
I'm the one in control I'm taking care
of this don't worry it'll be friendly
and musk can go out there and say hey
wait what this is happening it gives him
that distance a little bit I I hope
that's not what's going on good cop
cop yes exactly exactly right but
it does give him that opportunity I
think you're right and and let me go
through this in parts and then we have
uh we have I believe we have her here um
bring I'll bring her on in just a minute
Libs of tick tock because she has some
new information uh that'll raise an
eyebrow or two
um I mean they'll raise so many eyebrows
that we'll call you uh Doug burgum
can someone bring up that picture of
that weird Muppet someone bring it up we
have it somewhere so let me give you the
first part
um on Twitter we know beyond any shadow
of a doubt now and we can prove it and
we'll prove it with you you will take
part in an experiment with us today that
certain words have been demonetized on
Twitter on X yeah now that's important
because that means it's stories
um that you likely wanted to follow
right stories that would be Journal
important journalistically are
demonetized therefore Also
demonetization let's be clear we've seen
this with YouTube right the suppression
that comes with being demonetized you
have to understand people say oh we have
a right to be they don't have a right to
make money there well when you have a
platform like like Twitter if they're
following the footsteps of YouTube the
moment we were demonetized we saw a 90
drop in reach yeah we were accidentally
remonetized remember for four months we
saw a 100 increase in reach yet again
followers we were demonetized again boom
went down and it stands to reason their
business so they want to to direct
people to monetize content but here's
the thing journalism can't only be about
monetization and banning Words which is
what they're doing it's following
exactly the same footsteps as YouTube
and Facebook by the way that's what
we're seeing with x
investigative journalism will cease to
be so let me give you some examples the
Philly looting hey what do you do if the
keywords here are demonetized
so that and people didn't know nothing
about people sorry no you're not from
Philly
[Music]
I don't see colors you guys are black no
I didn't I didn't I didn't say so that I
identify as ours so my last name is oh
good for you yeah so you're a drunk so
JP
right with the U.S Virgin Islands the
the government over the Epstein
trafficking yeah words these were
demonetized words that's censoring let's
be clear demonetized means censoring
words January 6th oh and Shroyer we had
him on this show yep sentenced to 60
days in jail for just being there
January 6th not inciting violence
whatsoever hey journalists can't cover
that now the these stories right these
add up oh I want to cover oh wait I
can't cover the Philadelphia oh wait I
want to cover the Epstein sex oh wait I
can't cover it because I can't make a
living oh wait I want to cover someone
who's being he's being raked over the
coaster oh no wait I can't cover it
because I can't make anyone kind of like
on YouTube hey wait a second I wanted to
investigate a journalism oh wait they'll
just remove it because they don't
respect single party consent laws in
States this is does with this Watergate
could have never happened right and by
the way that's why there hasn't been a
Watergate again you think that you think
that Ukraine and Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden you don't it makes Watergate look
like Child's Play and by the way this
next one I just want to set this up
really quickly I think this is the one
that uh that lives a tick tock account
posted that kind of started this entire
thing I think this was one of the things
that led to her going wait a minute
what's going on here with this video not
being able to be put out yeah this was
the Burbank of California mayor
um gosh Constantine Anthony being
spanked by a drag queen uh at an event
with kids so it's clip Spanky
did you see that at the end she took it
in like wiggled a little bit at the end
what in his legs really the last hit
look at it let me see it let me watch it
again we want to but we have to all
right okay
right there
you've noticed that huh yeah that means
you're gay
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
we paid for it we're gonna use it all
right
so I believe we have her on now I'm
really glad to have her on and I from
what I heard maybe she can confirm there
might be some new developments with her
account yeah okay uh let's go to I guess
uh Haya raycheck you know
[Music]
come on I was going to say you know
where his lips of tick tock and you cut
me off before I could say you know
where's Libs of Tick Tock but I feel
like we have to get both like Macho
Randy Savage but macho man that's what
all right hi I'm sorry about that how
are you hey I'm great thanks for having
me so great to be here I am glad to have
you on here thank you for taking the
time I know you were in Flight um before
we get to some of these other questions
did I hear there's a development that
your entire account may have been
demonetized yeah so I actually did not
think it was possible for an entire
account to be demonetized and I actually
wrote on Twitter last week that I don't
think it's possible but this morning it
turns out that lives of tick tock is
completely demonetized right now I
tested the exact same word on my
personal account on Links of tick tock
and only the one on my personal account
is monetized so as of this moment right
now at 1109 Eastern lives of tick tock
on X the Free Speech platform your
entire account is fully demonetized yes
that's what it
equivalent of us with YouTube you're
you're a Trailblazer for X I'm sorry uh
well uh and the problem that happens
with that right you know is not just
being demonetized but then that usually
results in significantly reduced reach
right exactly yeah and and what
triggered this is is you just mentioned
the mayor Finke the mayor of Burbank so
I did a video confronting him and I
posted it to Elizabeth Tick Tock and you
do video production you know what goes
into it there's tons of time and energy
and money and we we spent all this
energy on this video and I post it and
it's being completely surprised it's
demonetized which was like the least of
the problems but I was upset that it was
being surprised and so I reached out to
some really high up people at Twitter
and it turned out that the word drag
queen was demonetizing it and so that's
what really started my whole like theory
of like oh there are certain words that
if you write those in a tweet then that
tweet will be demonetized so that's when
I started really testing out testing out
a bunch of different kind of uh words
right so it's so they they specifically
have demonetized wars and they told you
that the brass at Twitter I know you
reached out or sorry X they did respond
and say yes we can confirm that
so so actually I was like okay let me
test out some some words and I
discovered that the word Dragon was
demonetized and after I discovered it on
my own I was told that the word drag
queen is demonetized yeah but actually
now it's been fixed it was fixed right
away um within 24 hours wait don't they
fixed that one so what's going to have
to happen is you're going to have to
find all of the other words and then
they'll say oh no we'll fix it right
that's what happened with us in YouTube
oh yeah thanks thanks for letting us
know we'll fix it and then you find 20
other errors I don't I don't know
because because I think I I really
believe that Elon is trying his best I
think he has really good intentions and
I think that my whole investigation was
just it kind of just like opened a can
of worms and just like started the
discussion about it and I'm I'm really
hopeful that now he's gonna fix the
entire problem I don't I don't
anticipate that we're gonna have to come
up with the complete and total list of
words but if we do have to then I am
here for it but your whole account was
just demonetized this morning so it's a
separate issue I think I don't think
it's a word I think it's it's my account
status so that's a whole separate issue
okay well why do you think you're okay
my point is and maybe Elon right his
intentions are pure but that doesn't
mean that yakarinos are that doesn't
mean that the people who are in charge
of demonetizing individual accounts
right these people are still in in
Silicon Valley largely um that you're a
journalist a lot of people don't realize
because you you do it and it's
entertaining but what you do is
journalism and it's very important and
if journalists can't make a living off
of Journalism then the stories that
matter won't get out there people won't
know about the books in the libraries I
I'm I'm you're look you're being very
congenial I'm pissed I'm pissed I can't
believe your whole account's been
demonetized okay so let me give you some
more background information
um and I know a lot of people are gonna
freak out when I say this but Libs of
tick tock has barely made any money on
monetization from day one so they
started in February so we're talking
about like seven eight months ago we
have barely made any money and you see
journalists complaining on Twitter about
the monetization about how they're
barely making money and it should be
making more I made probably
like 80 percent less than those people
complaining on Twitter who have 250 000
followers and I have 2.5 million
followers so I never really looked at
Twitter as one of the ways that I was
going to monetize well that's because
that's because you weren't making money
it's the same thing with me I just found
out that the hardest twins wait like my
last check from Twitter was like was
literally 75 I believe
yeah I'm not joking I'm not joking 75
and then some I was talking with someone
they're going man I'm cleaning up on
Twitter I'm like you're bullshitting
the full like
location and decided that lives of tick
tock is probably making about three
million dollars a year on Twitter yeah
where is this money how do I get it
Teslas what you're about to you had a
question there Gerald because I wanted
to get to the words yeah so high really
quickly I mean Elon is and I hope you're
right like I hope Elon has these goals
see there's a few things that he can do
like you know maybe and what you don't
have to comment on this but put Alex
Jones back on the platform is a pretty
easy Free Speech bar right you may
disagree with that guy a lot but put him
back on the platform he may have good
intentions his entire pitch to creators
is come here and make money and so if
he's not monetizing an account that has
2.5 million followers and also has
incredible reach and important stuff
going out there what's the point
yeah yeah I agree with you and I think
he did write on Twitter a few days ago
that a lot of this these like sort of
things that are happening are just
leftovers from that whole trust and
safety uh Department that was there
before he bought Twitter and that's why
I really do think that he is trying his
best and I really believe that as soon
demonetized and we'll see how quickly he
responded Yes but here's the thing he
fixes it there's a difference between
fixing something because now there are
eyeballs on it because I will say this
if he said these are sort of remnants
from before well people weren't really
making money off of Twitter before right
that was kind of new in other words when
they introduced that to verified
accounts they would have also had to
create a process as to what would be
considered monetizable and not that
wasn't something that carried over and
so the idea of demonetized words that
that would by its very nature have to be
a new thing since Elon has been there
not saying he did it directly but there
are people in the post in their their
their their posts their positions of
authority you have what are some of the
specific words and we're going to
actually do this if you're if you're
okay with it we're going to have the
audience a B test with us live but um I
know that you've found some specific
words right you did some digging that uh
results in the demonetization of a post
right
yeah okay so you I think one of them you
found was porn the word porn right yeah
okay so we tested this we tested this
and we can bring this up right now we
tested a tweet porn is bad changed my
mind people can see that there and then
you can scroll there to reach so 21 000
views keep that in mind yeah well the
the reach isn't these are these were all
happening pretty so no advertising
whatsoever now we switched that tweet to
p o star symbol and is bad change my
mind we can bring this up right here
okay then you can scroll and we see ding
the ad now
that one look that makes sense if
they're trying that the problem is it's
not getting rid of porn I mean it's just
riddled with pornography yeah on Twitter
that's a separate problem but um we did
another one the word and tell me if I'm
missing the word ugly so uh I tweeted
out the word uh is AOC uh hot or ugly
childish and stupid yes but then again
so is Twitter and now I believe that
that has been fixed
yeah that's been fixed but there were
other words too I believe that were ugly
was demonetizable ugly was demonetizable
and another word that you found uh and
let me know trans was one right yeah
trans trans was one did you know that I
think that's been fixed now oh wow so
there was three I initially posted about
ten and seven out of those ten were
fixed within 24 hours right
a trans wasn't an ugly wasn't so you're
saying now then I think that's yeah let
me let me bring it up uh right now so
trans uh let's see right here I tweeted
out should trans dudes be able to
compete in Olympic water polo scroll you
can scroll boom now it is monetized so
so that is progress but that means it's
only happened because you publicly named
the words right and that shouldn't have
to take a journalist shouldn't have to
blow the whistle on journalists being
suppressed for them to no longer be
suppressed that's what I guess really
gets my goat and why I'm saying what you
do is so important the work is so
important
yeah well like I said before I think
that hopefully Elon did say that he's
looking into all this and he said on on
his Twitter space that this list needs
to be trimmed and he doesn't agree with
you know all the censorship so I mean I
think we will give him a little bit of
time and if it's not fixed and there's
still all these problems then we're
gonna have to just continue with this
investigation and just do word afterward
afterward I mean it's like a it's gonna
be like a full-time job maybe there's
that way to make like an automated
um account that just like posts words
um so maybe we'll have to do that but
let's do it let's do it right now we can
do so right now we have a lot of people
watching and everyone out there you can
share the show
um give us uh let's say let's go through
two or three words that you know
um are are demonetized right now we'll
have people in the in the audience right
now thousands go out and use them let's
let's uh give us a word
Ohio I mean you you can give us a word
one word that's demonstrated
what you tell me a word that you that
you found and then I'm going to ask the
I'll send out a tweet and we will also
have audience members send out tweets so
we can kind of have a sample pool
um
I mean there is questions about the word
fight if that was demonetized okay the
word fight you want to try that okay see
uh let's see um let me what we will
tweet out uh have tweet from our account
mission control
um should a biological do to be able to
fight I'm sorry beat up a female in the
octagon
let's tweet that out okay and let's see
if it that gets uh demonetized and you
guys out there use the word fight uh
people who are watching right now and uh
let's see what we will get that back in
about a minute we will see if it's
monetized or demonetized yes Mr Hodge
one of the Hodge twins how about
something has to do with Hunter Biden
maybe we have his uh tweet with himself
SD monetized I don't know hi did you see
anything that had to do with Hunter
specifically
I didn't test that yet but I did test uh
Putin and Ukraine and zelenski and at
first Putin was demonetized and then a
couple hours later it not hours even
minutes it was it was fixed so I don't
know with that but maybe we could try
Pizza in again okay so let's try Putin
um
I will just say uh uh uh let's tweet out
from my account
um what do you get when two
Collide zielinski and Putin
well might be demonetized okay
you know what what do you get when two
sphincters collide
zielinski and Putin let's put that out
there and we'll see if that's
demonetized and then you guys try around
maybe we should have a hashtag going
test like hashtag test Twitter words
right now there you go hashtag Twitter
word test Twitter word test let's bring
it up hashtag Twitter word test
technically whatever I was doing it one
word at a time just because you don't
know what other words in the sentence
might be demonetized so to really find
out which exact words the most effective
way is to do one word at a time all
right that's what you found out the word
innocent was monetized innocent I mean
the word innocent probably because they
didn't want more than that well probably
because I didn't want people like you
know Trevor Bauer saying hey I'm
innocent like not if not if page six
says you're not
uh I got a couple of words here actually
from suggestions so a furry furry furry
would be a good one for us to test and
also pedo
yeah let's type pedo okay how about
Republican yeah all right so from our
account let's just let's just try just I
think that we should be fine I don't
like right those shouldn't be yeah I
think we're saying yeah yeah I don't
like
pedos or I don't like pedophiles let's
try one of each let's just get those out
there all right and we do have the the
word fight the test on the word fight uh
ready if you are ready oh do we have the
test the word fight hiya this is
happening in real time sorry you can't
take part because
anyway
yeah there we go all right all right
okay let's see what's that what are the
results from the word fight
that's good that's progress we'll see if
as soon as we have the rest of these as
we we did tweet out you know I tweet out
that I don't like pedophiles because I'm
I'm not afraid to take the unpopular
positions here at this program
we'll take the risks so you don't have
to
um what other words uh what do you think
there yeah all right we've got some
pedophiles let's see
all right I don't like pedos oh wow
Amazon well that's apt
so look so those are monetized it seems
like they're being less aggressive by
the way I heard through the grapevine
that those were demonetized last week
and then after I posted about it a bunch
of words that were previously
demonetized were monetized so a lot of
these problems did get fixed yeah the
primary problem though right is that
there's no transparency in other words
they could fix it and then change it
next week or then they can there needs
to be an actual policy that they make
this very clear right especially for
Content creators and journalists because
look the big thing is they're pitching
people to leave other platforms and come
over to Twitter right if they're content
creators but if you do that based on you
know misleading information well now
people they've hopped to a new lily pad
and they're being they can end up being
just as screwed that's you know not just
for journalists but for everyone yeah or
give us list of which words are
demonetized like if people are saying
like hey look these words we don't
approve of we're going to demonetize
your account okay so just give us that
list and we can make a decision I don't
know if we want to censor ourselves or
not yes no that's absolutely right by
the way did you enjoy all the Jewish
holidays this September
yeah it's actually still going on we're
middle of a holiday right now oh okay
well so yeah for a very for very
industrious people lots of days off this
September we know that was Sam from HR
I'm not a fall holiday everybody comes
in he's like I'm like you're still it's
another holiday Sam
it's through though very close together
yeah well all right yeah Gerald look I I
just I want to I want to be clear too
like we we are fans of Elon if he does
the kind of the right thing of course
and I think that I would take your
position uh if if he had not hired Linda
yakarina I would probably be more fully
on board like hey just give him time
don't worry about it but with that
higher it didn't make me necessarily
some questions about elon's kind of
motives maybe but I just don't trust her
so as much as I feel like Elon Musk is
pushing in the right direction that
higher to me was incredibly suspect and
I don't trust her to do the right thing
when it comes to free speech I just
don't think that's the world she comes
from
I mean she is she does answer to him so
I think at the end of the day like he's
the one in charge you have to give him
credit for getting rid of the whole
election Integrity yeah
and all that garbage we do we absolutely
do we credit him for that we sing his
Praises when he does stuff like that I
know that he ultimately is the guy but
he's running SpaceX he's running Tesla
he's doing a whole bunch of other stuff
the reason she was brought in is so that
he didn't have to run the day-to-day I
just don't want her to do something that
he finds out about three months later
and then has to undo so you're right
eventually it can be undone but what if
it happens in October of 2024 and he
doesn't find out until December that's
my main concern right now and so I I do
like I said I think he's headed the
right direction I'm just very concerned
about what she will be able to do and
when he'll be able to find out about it
yeah well and with people like hi out
there the work that she does is very
important um and you know it's important
that there are platforms out there
um that will stand their ground uh I
would like to see Elon do and obviously
I'm biased but you know Rumble Chris
pavlot who's Canadian he flipped the
bird the entire French government he
said no absolutely not just now with
Canada he said he's never been more
embarrassed that guy will not will not
falter will not Wilt you have not seen
this take place there and I think that I
do think that Elon is that way I don't
think that the communication publicly
has been as clear and um you know I
think
[Music]
thank you
my checks are so small yeah I think so
yeah yeah we need to dive into that a
little bit further yeah I mean I feel
like you know like I don't know cardi B
is getting like Samsung and mine's like
the the copycat Alibaba
sorry well you did have Amazon one time
all right uh high up we're going to
continue this here on Mud Club but was
there any is there are there any other
updates or any information that you
think is is pivotal for people to know
before we continue on mug clubbing with
this experiment
um no I'm gonna tweet out now that
Elizabeth Tick Tock is completely
demonetized and we'll see what happens I
I think Elon I'm hopeful he'll respond
and fix it
um and yeah like I said I think he has
good intentions I'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt but I will also
hold Twitter accountable
um you know I I will call out censorship
I will call out these problems
um but I do think that they're gonna get
fixed when we call them out so yeah I'm
gonna continue doing this and hopefully
we'll get some answers all right well
stay with us for a little bit uh people
right now if you're watching on YouTube
there is no saving you but if you're
watching on Rumble you click this button
right there you get to continue watching
seamlessly you join mug Club you get the
Hodge one's new show coming October 12th
along with Alex Jones Show along with
our double show every day the Friday
show Brian Callan show Mr guns and gear
Nick depaolo every day sign up it
doesn't burn there's a little bit of a
staying when you click yeah click uh you
know they click the Mud Club button hey
uh thank you very much Rumble YouTube
piss off
thank you